We started last
time on protection.
You remember the model
that we're considering?
We've got some client
communicating over the Internet
with some server.
And we said that there are
three main technical problems
that we're going
to look to address.
There is the problem
of authentication,
the problem of authorization and
the problem of confidentiality.
Today what we're
going to do is we're
going to talk mostly about
this issue of authentication,
but I want to just return
to some of the details
that we were talking
about at the end of class
last time so that you guys
all get the important bits out
of our discussion
of the RSA protocol.
Remember, last time
we started talking
about these are the main
requirements of a protection
system.
And we drew a diagram that
said that at the top level
we want to have an
application that is protected.
Underneath that
we're going to have
a set of security primitives.
And then, underlying
all of this,
we're going to
have cryptography.
Cryptography is going to be
sort of the essential technique
that we use to
enable protection.
We talked briefly about
several different types
of cryptography.
Remember, we had
our model where we
have A is sending through
some box which takes the data
and transforms it using some
cryptographic transform.
And then that cryptographically
transformed data gets
transmitted and then is reverse
transformed or untransformed
at the other side and it
comes out to the receiver.
What cryptography
does is we said
that we want this open model
where there is some key k1 here
and some key k2
here that are used
to decide how this
transform operator works
and this untransform operator
works on the other side.
We talked about a shared key
case where k1 is equal to k2.
And the appendix A of
the chapter in the notes
goes over a shared key
protocol called DES
that is fairly commonly used.
The basic idea behind
shared key cryptography
is typically that both
sides have this key
and we're going to transform the
data by combining the message
stream that is coming
from A together
with the key in some
way, say, for example,
by xoring the data in
many different ways
or permuting the data
around and then xoring it
with the key in some
combination of ways.
That's sort of what
the DES protocol does.
It's just multiple
rounds, basically,
of permuting and xoring the
data over and over again.
The idea is that if an
attacker doesn't know the key,
it's very hard for them
to reverse this process
without having the
key, but if you
know the key it's relatively
easy to reverse the process.
We also talked a little bit
about public key cryptography
where k1 is not equal to k2.
In this case, we started
talking about this protocol
RSA which is an example
of a public key protocol.
If you remember,
RSA has some set
of rules for actually doing
the transformation of data.
The basic idea is
that we're going
to get a private
key and a public key
here, which is going to
consist of this prime number
plus the product of
these two prime numbers
and this private key k
which is going to consist
of the other prime number
and the product of these two
things.
Now we have this way in which
we can transform the data.
What this transform box does
is simply raise the message
to the power of e modulo n and
we have the reverse transform.
This is just a specific
mathematical operation.
The reason that this
mathematical operation works
is that the intuition is that
it is relatively easy to take
something to an exponent.
I can take a number
and exponentiate it
without doing very much work.
But in order for an attacker
to compromise this system, that
is in order to
discover, for example,
what the private key is, in
this case, what this value d is,
given just the public key
which consists of e and n,
the attacker is going to be able
to factor this number n, which
turns out to be very
difficult to do.
Essentially, breaking
this cryptographic system
comes down to be able to
factor a very large number.
And that turns out to be,
computationally, very,
very difficult to do.
So that's sort of the
intuition behind the protection
of this scheme.
The nice thing
about RSA is it has,
in most public key
cryptographic protocols
is that they have this property
that the reverse is also true.
So I can transform
using exponentiation
with the public key
or the private key
and I can reverse transform
using the opposite.
If I transform with
the public key,
I can reverse transform with
the private key and vise versa.
So we are going to exploit
this property a lot
when we're talking about
this kind of cryptography.
Just to sort of point
out that this is hard,
this is an estimate from
the RSA Security Company
about how many compute
years on modern computers
it would take to factor an
RSA key of a given link.
So the bottom is the key
link in bytes on the x-axis
and then the y-axis is the
machine years to factor.
If the machine years
to factor was 1,000,
that means it would take 1,000
machines working together
one year to do this or one
machine 1,000 years to do it.
So you see that the y-axis
here is going up exponentially.
So to factor a 500 byte
key is not that hard.
It takes maybe a few months
of compute time to do it.
To factor a 2,000
byte key takes this
a ridiculously long time, ten
to the 16th years it is going
to take to factor this thing.
So there is just no way that,
at least modern computers,
are ever going to be
able to actually perform
this factoring using currently
known algorithms for factoring.
It is, of course,
possible that somebody
will develop a very
fast factoring algorithm
or that there will be some
fundamental breakthrough
like quantum computing that
will make it possible to factor
very large numbers.
But, at this point, this is
sort of the estimate of how long
it would take to do this.
So, by using long keys, you
can be sort of guaranteed
that somebody won't be able to
actually factor this number.
So by using a
factoring-based attack on RSA
that sort of won't be able
to break it in this way.
The largest RSA number that
has been factored to date
is some 500 odd byes,
something like 520 bytes,
so RSA has challenges
for the largest
numbers that can be factored.
So we're sort of just
barely on this curve
is where the largest
numbers that have
been factored to date.
And these are typically
some collection
of machines on the Internet.
Somebody gets 1,000
machines on the Internet
and they chew on this problem.
I think, in this case, it took
1,000 machines three months
to find a factor of
this 500 byte key.
This is the basic idea now.
What we're going to do is use
these cryptography algorithms,
this math to build up
a set of primitives
that we can use to actually
accomplish our security
goals that we want.
And I put these on the
board briefly last time.
But I didn't talk
at all about what
the actual functionality is.
And we're going to spend a
lot of time talking about two
of these primitives
today, and then we'll
talk about a few more
of them next time.
We have two sets of
primitives in particular
that we are interested in.
One set is called
sign and verify.
And the other set is
called encrypt or decrypt.
And we're going to use sign
and verify basically as a way
to achieve authentications.
Remember, authentication
is the process
of verifying that a message
actually came from who
it was supposed to come from.
And we're going to use
encrypt and decrypt in order
to provide confidentiality to
guaranty that somebody who we
don't want to be able to read a
message, somebody who shouldn't
be able to read a message can,
in fact, not read that message.
Let me just illustrate
a simple example.
Suppose we're using
a public key system,
we can say suppose
we use something
like RSA to encode a
message m with some key,
say we're sending a
message from A to B,
we use it to encode some
key, say, kA private.
What this notation
means is that whoever
has A's private key encodes
that message or transforms
that message using a
cryptographic protocol using,
say, for example, kA private.
What this says is
Alice, perhaps as A,
runs her RSA algorithm
on the message
and generates some
encoded thing.
This is an encryption.
We're going to use this
encoding with the private key
to sign a message.
When Alice encodes this
with her private key
what that means is that somebody
who has Alice's public key
can decode this,
because we said if you
encode with the private key
somebody with the public key
can decode.
For example, if she
sends this to Bob,
Bob is going to be
able to decode this.
At first that seems like, well,
what good does that do us?
Bob can read this message.
But the thing is
if Bob can decode
this, what he knows, with
very high certainty is
that the person who
encoded this message
had access to A's private key.
If he is willing to trust that,
in fact, the only person who
has access to A's
private key is A herself,
then he can be
reasonably confident
that this message came from A.
You guys all sort of
see how that works.
What we say is that
Alice signs this message.
And, by signing
this message, she
is able to sort of give
Bob some confidence
that this message, in
fact, came from her.
We can also do
the opposite thing
where, say, for example, Alice
is sending a message to Bob.
She can take m and
sign it with kB public.
Sorry, she can encrypt
it with kB public.
She is going to use
the RSA algorithm.
She is going to
encrypt this message.
And, when she
encrypts this message,
she is going to basically
use the RSA algorithm using
kB public.
And what is going
to happen is now
she is going to be reasonably
assured that this message is
going to be able to
only be read by Bob
because only Bob presumably
has his own private key.
What I've shown here makes
this look very simple.
I sort of said it as
though we're simply
taking this message and running
the basic RSA algorithm,
as I showed it, on the
message in order to do sign
and in order to encrypt.
It turns out that actually
getting sign and encrypt
to work property requires
some fairly sophisticated sort
of reasoning about
the RSA algorithm.
For example, when you're
encrypting something,
if the message is very
small, it turns out
that if you encrypt a small
message simply using the RSA
algorithm as I presented it that
it's relatively easy to break
the RSA algorithm.
The RSA algorithm becomes
vulnerable with very small
messages.
That means the encryption
process actually
needs to pad out the
message to some longer link.
It needs to put unused bytes
at the end of every message
in order for it to be secure.
These sign and encrypt
algorithms themselves sort of
have to do some additional
work on top of the basic RSA
algorithm in order to be secure.
And that additional
work is sort of
beyond the scope of this class.
It requires a certain degree
of mathematical sophistication
that we are not going
to rely on here.
You can go take an extra
class about cryptography
and learn about how these sign
and encrypt algorithms actually
work, but the basic idea is
that you can sort of grasp it
by just seeing RSA.
These things are hard to build.
Now that we have sort
of quickly reviewed
the basics of
protection and we've
seen the sign and verify and
encrypt and decrypt primitives,
now what I want to do
is to talk a little bit
about how we can actually
start building up, solving
this problem of
authenticating a user.
When we authenticate a user
we have two objectives.
One thing we're
trying to achieve
is to determine who
is making a request.
In practice, it's
going to turn out,
in fact, that we
may not officially
be able to say exactly the
specific person who is being
able to make the request.
We may only be able to say that
the same principle or person
or computer as before
is making the request,
or the same principle who had
some special privileged piece
of information that
the person before
had is making this request.
We may not be able
to actually associate
this with a physical
person, but at least we're
going to be able to know that
we've seen somebody who had
this same information before.
We're trying to
make sure that this
is sort of consistent
with a series of requests
that we've seen in the past.
A simple example is I lot onto
Amazon, I create a password.
Now, anybody who I
give that password to
can log onto Amazon.
And all the system
can say is that it
knows that whoever it is
who is accessing definitely
has my password
information and sort of it
doesn't know officially
that it is actually
the same physical person.
The other thing, though, that
we want authentication to do
is to tell us basically that
the message that was sent
is equal to the message
that was received.
We want it to be the case
that if Alice sends a message
to Bob, that when Bob
receives that message,
we want him to
have some assurance
that, in fact, that message was
actually the message that Alice
tried to send.
And we're going
to talk about how
this is sort of going to relate
to the problem of integrity
that we talked about before,
verifying that a message hasn't
been corrupted in transmission.
But this is actually
a harder requirement
because we might need
to not only worry
about sort of random bits being
flipped by the communication
channel but we need to worry
about some malicious person
coming in and physically
actively modifying
the bytes of the message.
Authentication is
sort of the first step
that we need to have
in any secure system
because authentication
is going to be the key.
We have to authenticate
a user before we
can authorize the user.
Before we can say, yes,
this user is allowed,
we have to figure
out who the user is.
And, similarly, we can use
authentication, this process
of figuring out who
a user is to help
us to build up audit trails.
Remember we said
audit trails are
something that is important.
Once we figure
out who a user is,
we can keep logs of which
user it was that connected
to our machine.
Let's look at a simple model
of how authentication works.
The idea is as follows.
We have our principle,
say, for example,
a user who is sending a
request to some server.
And this request might be
something, for example,
like buy Apple stock.
And the server's
job is to determine
whether this request is actually
authentic, whether it actually
came from the user it
claims to come from
and whether the message
that was received
is actually the
message that was sent.
The way it's going
to do this is we're
going to introduce something
we call a guard that
is at the front end
of this server that
takes in all the
incoming requests and is
in charge of
authenticating them.
And then this guard is going
to dispatch results off
to any of the services
that the server provides.
It is going to say
if the request is
authentic it is going to invoke
the service that we need.
In other words, this guard
is the type of mediator
that sits in between all the
requests between the principle
and the service that
it is trying to access
and the guard is going
to be the thing that
does all of our authentication.
Now the question is what is it
exactly that the guard does?
What are the processes
that the guard
has to go through in order
to authenticate a user?
And, before we talk about the
specific technical solution,
I want to sort about two
things that are really
going on when you're
trying to figure out
who it is that is requesting
and whether you're
going to allow that person
to do what they want to do.
So the issue is,
essentially, as follows.
There is this question
about is the computer that
is making this request actually
have the appropriate keys
to make this request?
Does it have the
appropriate password
to be allowed to
make this request?
Then there is this
other question
which is do I trust this user?
Is this somebody who I
want using my service?
Suppose that I go to E*Trade
and say I want to buy Apple.
How does E*Trade decide
whether or not it trusts me,
whether I'm somebody who is
allowed to buy Apple stock from
them or not?
So they have some
process for doing that.
You have this mechanical
process of authentication.
And then we have this sort
of psychological process
of determining whether or
not you trust somebody.
So this authentication is
going to be a technical thing
and we are going to describe
this as being psychological.
What these things are connected
by is some notion of a name.
What the authentication
says is, for example,
Sam wants to buy Apple.
It determines that I am,
in fact, the person who
is making the
request, that it is
able to verify that I am
the one who is actually
making the request.
What trust is
responsible of doing
is determining whether or
not Sam should actually be
allowed to make this request.
And this is not something
that we necessarily
have a technical solution to.
Different computer systems
have different ways
of determining whether or not
they should trust each other.
For example, when you go
to a service on the Web,
you make a decision about
whether you trust that service
based on some sort
of way that you
have of evaluating the service.
Maybe your Mom told you that
E*Trade is the best place
to buy stocks on
the Internet with.
You trust your Mom and so,
therefore, you trust E*Trade.
Or maybe you saw an
advertisement for E*Trade
and you think any company that
has enough money to advertise
on the side of the freeway
must be a trustworthy company
and, therefore, I trust you.
Similarly, E*Trade, presumably
determines that they trust you
based on, well, one
thing they might do is,
you might give them a
bank account number,
and your bank might say, yes,
this person has enough money
to make this request.
That is a way that they might
decide that they trust you.
Alternatively, E*Trade
gives out loans,
so maybe they go talk to
your credit reporting agency,
and the credit reporting
agency says, yeah,
this guy is trustworthy.
He has a high credit
score so, therefore,
E*Trade will let you borrow
$1,000 to invest in the stock
market or something.
This issue of trust
is one that we
don't have a
technical solution to,
but it is absolutely
an essential part
of authenticating and
authorizing a user
to use a computer system.
So it's worth just
bearing this in mind
that any time you're
building a computer
system you need
to think about how
it is that you determine whether
a user is trustworthy or not.
And this goes both ways, both
for the user of the system,
how do they determine
that you're trustworthy,
and for the system,
how do you determine
that the users are trustworthy?
Now the key problem is
focusing on this sort
of authentication problem.
What is the technical
meat of how we're actually
going to authenticate a user?
One of these problems
is determining
that this message that
was sent was actually
the message that was received.
Here is a simply proposal
that I might have
which is I might compute
one of these CRC checks.
These checksums that
we talked about when
we were talking about networking
that we used to determine
whether or not the message has
been corrupted in transmission.
It turns out that is
not going to work.
You might also think
the way that you
are going to insure that
the person who is requesting
the message is actually
who they claim to be
is, for example, using
our encryption primitive.
If we had a one time
pad available to us,
we might encrypt
the entire stream
of data that is going across.
And then we would
think well, there
is no way that somebody
on the other end,
unless they are
authorized to read this,
will actually be
able to read it.
And, therefore, this is going to
give us some guaranty about who
is making the request.
Neither of these things quite
works, and let me explain why.
Integrity, in the sense that we
studied it previously in 6.033,
is not equal to authenticity,
is not equal to confidentiality.
And the reason is as follows.
Let's just look at
a simple example.
Suppose there is
Alice who is sending
a message to some server,
and suppose this server
is something where
Alice doesn't really
mind if her request
is seen in public
but she wants to make sure that
the server actually receives
the request that she made.
So she cares about it
being the right request,
but she doesn't care about
it being a secret request.
Maybe Alice says I want to
donate $100 to Save the Whales.
She says I don't
care if anybody knows
that I want to save the whales.
That's a noble and
respectful cause.
In fact, I am proud of the fact
that I want to save the whales.
So anybody who wants to
can look at this message.
But I really only want to
give Save the Whales $100.
I want to make sure
that somebody doesn't
mess with this message and some
Save the Whale activist doesn't
change this message to
be $10,000 so that I
don't lose a bunch of money.
Let's look at some
techniques that we
might use to sort of guaranty
that this is the case.
One thing we might do is, for
example, use a one time pad.
Suppose Alice and the server
share a random bit string.
Alice might encode, might xor
the message that she transmits,
and then the server
might apply the xor again
with the same bit string
and get the message back.
The problem with
this is that this
doesn't prevent some
malicious user or Lucifer
from coming into
the middle of this
and interfering with this byte
string as it is transmitted.
Even though Lucifer cannot
actually look at the message,
he can manipulate the byes
to his heart's content.
And he may get lucky and change
the bytes so that it says
something like donate some
different amount of money
to save the whales or he may
just garble Alice's requests
so it cannot be processed.
So one time pad is
not going to work.
Now, the other alternative
I said we can talk about
would be something
like using a CRC.
What Alice would do is send
m followed by the CRC of m.
The problem with this
is that now Lucifer
can look at this
message as it comes
across the wire
and the checksum,
and he can simply
change the message
to say whatever he wants and
then recomputed the checksum.
So the checksums, as we have
talked about them so far,
are good for handling the
case of non-malicious attacks
or non-malicious problems
like a byte gets changed
in transmission or there is
some error in transmission,
but they don't solve this
problem of preventing somebody
from tampering with
the message and being
able to detect when that
tampering also effects the CRC.
If you think about
this for a minute,
the property that
we want sort of
feels like some combination
of these two things.
Basically, what we want is some
checksum-like operation such
that we know that the only
person who could have possibly
written this checksum was
somebody who access to some key
that Alice has like
Alice's private key.
We want a checksum that
is dependent on a key,
and we want this
checksum to have
some fairly strong properties.
We want this checksum to
be resistant to these kinds
of attacks that we talked
about Lucifer applying.
In particular, we
want the checksum
to be resistant to Lucifer
modifying the message.
So the checksum should
detect that this message was
modified, if it was modified.
We also want it to be able to
detect other transformations
of the message.
For example, suppose that rather
than modifying m, changing
something, Lucifer just reorders
some of the words in it,
keeps exactly the same
characters and exactly
the same length but just
switches some things around.
And there are other
kinds of things
that we might want to be
able to resist as well.
For example, taking
exactly the same message
and sticking a little bit of
extra data onto the end of it,
appending something
to the message.
There is a bunch of
different sort of properties
that we want whatever
this thing is
that is going to allow us to
do authentication to have.
Let's look at the
sort of model for how
our basic authentication
system is going to work.
It is really pretty
straightforward
and is going to rely
on using our sign
and verify primitives
that I am erasing.
The idea is as follows.
We have Alice over here
that is sending a message.
That message is going
to go into our sign
cryptographic primitive,
it's going to be transformed
and is going to come over
here to our verify box,
and then it is going to
come out on the other side
at the server.
And the sign is going to have
some k1 that gets fed into it
and verify is going to have
some k2 that gets fed into it.
And the idea is that in
addition to signing the message
we are also going to
transmit the message itself.
So this is going to be sort
of like this idea of putting
a CRC on a message,
but this thing
that we are going to do
when we sign is going
to provide this sort of better
properties than the basic CRC
did.
The idea is this is a small
bit of additional information
that gets transmitted with the
message that allows the server
to be confident that, in
fact, the message that
was transmitted came from
Alice and that it has not
been corrupted along the way.
This is the basic idea now k1
comes in, it gets transmitted,
goes through the verify
box, and the verify box
reports yes or no, this message
was correct or was not correct.
And the server also has
access to the message.
If the server gets yes
in the message then
it continues to process it.
And we have two kinds of ways
of doing authentification
that correspond to shared key
and public key cryptography.
If k1 is equal to k2 we say that
this little bit of information
that we have transmitted is a
MAC, a message authenticator.
When you are using shared
key cryptography that
is the bit of additional
information that gets
transmitted.
And when k1 is not
equal to k2, that
is if we're using
public key cryptography,
we call this bit of additional
information a signature.
To give you a very
simple example
of what a signature might
consist of, suppose we have
a message m.
In public key
cryptography, a simple kind
of signature that
you can compute
is to take the hash of m.
And then take that
thing and encode it
with Alice's private key.
This is a simple
kind of a signature
that we might
attach to a message.
And this has the
properties we want,
which is that we believe that
only Alice could have actually
encoded this message because
we belief that only Alice has
access to her private key.
And so when somebody uses
the public key to decode this
they get something back which
is a hash of the message.
And we call this a
cryptographically secure hash.
It is some way of combining
the bits of the message
together such that when the
server computes the hash of m,
the probability that it
matches this hash that
was in the signature
that Alice sent,
they will match if the
messages are the same.
And, if the hash was computed
on a different message
than the message that
the server receives,
the probability
is very, very low
that these two messages
are, in fact, the same.
So they say it has a low
collision probability.
It's very unlikely that some
m prime that is not equal to m
has the same hash as m.
That's what a cryptographically
secure hash provides us.
And, again, cryptographically
secure hashes
are another kind of sort
of mathematical technique.
There is a set of algorithms
for driving these things.
The appendix talks about
a common one which is used
called sha-1.
And sha-1, it turns
out, has recently
been shown to have some higher
probability of collisions
than was previously thought.
And there is a new
protocol called sha-256
which is still
believed to be secure.
But sha-1, the S-H-A, which
stands for secure hash,
is one that is very commonly
used in the world today.
So this is a simple
example of a signature
and it allows basically
for the server
to verify one by decoding the
message with Alice's public key
that the message
actually came from Alice,
and this hash allows it
to be reasonably assured
that the message has
not been tampered with.
If the message had been tampered
with the hash wouldn't match,
and if this signature had
been tampered with then
the receiver wouldn't have
been able to decode this thing
and get something back
that made any sense.
Or, again, the hash
probably wouldn't match.
This is the basic solution
for doing authentication.
This screen is too low.
Now that we've sort
of seen a method
for authenticating
a message, there
are sort of a bunch of little
details that we left hanging.
In particular, one of the
details that we haven't yet
addressed is, suppose we are
using some public key based
mechanism like this,
I haven't yet told you
or we haven't talked about
how it is that somebody
would learn Alice's public key?
We sort of just
assumed that whoever
is receiving the message
is able to figure out
what Alice's public key is.
And one thing you could imagine
is that Alice goes around
and physically meets
everybody who she would ever
want to give a key
to and she hands
them a slip of paper that has
her public key written on it.
But, obviously, one, that's not
how the Internet works clearly
because we have some
cryptographic protocols that
allow us, we don't
have to meet everybody
and we can still get established
secure communication channels.
And, two, that just doesn't
sound very scalable.
It doesn't sound like
a great solution.
This is the key
distribution problem.
This is going to apply
mostly for the case
of public key cryptography.
In the case of shared
key cryptography,
this method I am going
to show you in a minute
is not going to
apply necessarily
to shared key cryptography,
but I will show you
a way in which we can use
public key cryptography
to sort of bootstrap or to
exchange a shared key which
we can then use over our
communication channel.
This is the key
distribution problem
for public key
cryptographic systems.
One solution, if Alice cannot
physically meet with Bob,
one thing that you might imagine
doing is you could just have
Alice send a message to Bob
saying here is my public key.
Or, better yet, Alice's public
key is, A's public key is X.
But this isn't a
very good approach
because how does B
actually know that this was
Alice that sent this message?
This could have been some
Lucifer who said, oh,
by the way, Alice's key is this.
And now B thinks that Alice's
key is, in fact, Lucifer's key.
And now Lucifer can
decode any message
that B wants to send to A.
So this isn't really
a very good approach
because if A just, sort
of out of the blue,
blurts out to be
my key is this then
it doesn't have any way of
actually knowing that this was,
in fact, A who
reported this key.
That doesn't solve our problem.
Instead, we are going to use a
technique called certificates.
Certificates work like this.
The idea with
certificates is that we
are going to introduce
a third-party who
I have shown here as Charles.
Let's suppose that Alice and
Bob know and trust Charles.
So they have already somehow
exchanged information
with Charles, exchanged
keys with him.
The idea is now suppose Alice
wants to send a message to Bob.
What she does is she
sends this message,
and she signs the message
using her private key.
That is what this S
parentheses m kApriv means.
Now what Bob is going
to do is say, well, I
don't know who this Alice is.
And rather than
simply asking Alice
for her public key, which
we have already said
is not a very good
idea, what Bob does
is he asks Charles
for her public key
because he trusts Charles and
he knows that Charles probably
knows something about Alice.
And what Charles responds
with is Alice's public key,
as well as he needs to
make sure that he, himself,
signs this message with his own
private key so that somebody
else cannot intercept the
message as it is coming back
and overwrite it.
He put his signature
on this message
that he sends back with
Alice's public key in it.
Now Bob has Alice's
public key, and he
can go ahead and
decode this message,
he can go ahead and verify
this message that Alice
tried to send to him.
So, in this, we call
this Charles here,
sometimes it is called a
CA, a certificate authority.
And the idea is that these
CAs, a small number of CAs
can service a very
large number of users.
So rather than having to
have every user exchange keys
with every other
user, each user just
exchanges keys with a few
certificate authorities.
And then, those certificate
authorities, sort of act
like these hubs that
propagate keys out
into the rest of the users.
This is a very
simple way in which
you might be able to
disseminate a public key.
We will talk a little
bit later on about sort
of a more formal
way of reasoning
about how public
keys are disseminated
and how these kinds of
webs of trust are built up,
but this is just a
simple way to sort
of start thinking about
how public keys might
be disseminated automatically
over the Internet.
What I want to do now
is just briefly turn,
with the last few
minutes, to this question
of how we actually establish
a secure communication
channel between two parties.
This is going to
get at our property,
the sort of establishing a
confidential communication
channel.
We are going to talk
a little bit about how
we establish confidentiality.
And so the idea is
that we want to find
some way that we can encrypt the
communication between our two
parties.
And what we are going to
do is first authenticate
the user using a
technique like this,
and then what we
are going to do is
use public key to authenticate.
This is establishing a
secure communication channel.
We are going to use public
key to authenticate.
But what often
happens in practice
in the Internet is that you
use public key to authenticate,
and then what you
are going to do
is use a shared key
cryptography protocol
to actually encrypt
the information that
is flowing back and forth
between the two parties.
And the reason for that is
if you sort of looked at,
even though I said that these
public key methods like RSA,
it's easier to exponentiate
than it is to factor.
It turns out that
exponentiation in RSA
is still relatively expensive
because exponentiation
requires, these keys
are very long, they
are thousands of
bytes long, so you
are taking these long
messages and taking them
to very large powers.
Doing that is
computationally expensive.
You get these very big
numbers that computers are not
terribly good at handling.
And so it has a big
impact on performance
if you use public key
cryptography all the time.
Instead, often
times what is done
is we use public key
cryptography to sort of,
as I said, bootstrap the
process of exchanging a shared
key between two servers.
That is what we
are going to see.
We are going to see how we
can then exchange a shared
key which we can then use
to encrypt the communication
between two parties.
This is a little
puzzle for you guys.
What I am going to put up
now is a broken protocol
and see if you can figure out,
in the next few minutes, how
it is broken.
It is not very broken but it is
broken in kind of a subtle way.
This is a protocol
called Denning-Sacco.
And when it was
originally proposed,
the original proposers of it
actually got it wrong, too.
And they presumably thought
about it for a while
before they got it wrong.
This is meant to
be an illustration
that designing cryptographic
protocols is hard
and it needs to be
something that you need
to think about very carefully.
Here is the protocol.
Suppose that Alice wants to send
a message between Alice and Bob
and we have our
certificate authority.
Alice says to the
certificate authority,
I would like to do some
communication with Bob.
And my name is Alice.
What Bob sends back is
one of these certificates,
a signed message that has
Alice's public key in it
and Bob's public key.
We call these signed
messages certificates.
These come from the
certificate authority.
And they basically are a
way that if Alice trusts
the certificate authority she
can decode Bob's public key
and be reasonably
assured that this is,
in fact, Bob's public key.
She is also going to get
a certificate for herself
that she can send
to Bob so that Bob
doesn't have to go contact the
certificate authority again.
She is going to
send this thing that
has been signed the
certificate authority which
is going to allow Bob
to authenticate her.
So she does that.
What she sends to Bob
is her own certificate
which is this little thing
shown here on the left.
And then she also sends to
Bob a proposed shared key.
This is kAB.
And she signs that proposed
key with her own private key.
When she signs this key
with her private key
that means that
Bob can be assured
that this is an authentic
message, in fact, from Alice.
And then she encrypts
it with Bob's public key
so that only Bob can be
the one who can decode it.
So only Bob will actually
see the contents,
see what this key is.
And these Ts that I have shown
here are simply timestamps,
and I will explain
to you why those
are important in a minute.
We need timestamps that go
along with these things.
So this proposed key
has been both signed
with her private
key and encrypted
with Bob's public key.
And now Bob can go ahead and
send messages back to Alice.
And he can encrypt those
messages using kAB,
using a shared key encryption
mechanism which, as we said,
is more efficient.
So these guys can exchange
a bunch of information
with each other in this way.
This is an example of a
cryptographic protocol.
I said there was a bug.
Let's try and debug
it a little bit.
And, to get at that,
let's talk about what some
of the properties of
cryptographic protocols
that we would like.
One property we would like
is what is called freshness.
What freshness means is
that I am reasonably assured
that this message is recent.
It came from recent history.
And this is what we
need the timestamps for.
We need to make sure that this
message is, in fact, a message
that is relatively new.
It is not an old message that
I generated before that is now
being sent back to me again.
That is what we are going to
use the timestamps here for.
We also want to make sure that
the message is appropriate.
And, by appropriate, I am
actually the intended recipient
of this message and the
sender of this message
is actually who the sender of
this message claimed to be.
This message actually
should be applied right now.
This message makes sense.
And then, finally, the
third property we want
is something called
forward secrecy.
What this says is
essentially we should
be able to change the
cryptographic keys that we
are using at some
point in the future.
Say, for example, if our
keys become compromised, we
should be able to
change the keys
and our method should
continue to work.
This approach is
pretty clearly true.
Alice could request a new key.
And then you could imagine
some way in which Alice could
create a new key and
send that new key to Bob
and we can sort of
start all over again.
The two properties that
are really interesting
are this freshness property and
this appropriateness property,
and they are the two
properties that I
want to talk about
a little bit more.
And if you think about
what the kinds of attacks
are that somebody could
apply on this thing,
well, one attack
they could apply
would be an attack on
the sort of cryptographic
transform itself.
A brute force attack where
you try and factor the keys,
we said that is hard.
Another attack that
they could apply
would be a so-called
replay attack.
There is a crypto attack
and so-called replay attack.
This is that somebody
might sort of
reuse a message that they saw
transmitted over the network
before.
Some Eve or Lucifer
might overhear a message
and then might try and
resend that message in order
to get the server
to do something.
Suppose there is a message
that tells the server
to take some action in the
outside world, open a door,
so you might save up a message
that somebody else had sent
before that said open the door.
And then you might
resend it in order
to get the door open when
you wanted it to open.
We want to prevent that.
And we are going to use
timestamps to do this.
And getting the
timestamps to work out
is a little bit tricky.
If the sender and the
receiver have perfectly
synchronized clocks,
you might just
say as long as the timestamp
is within the first few
milliseconds that is fine.
But if that is not
true then you need
to do something a little
bit more sophisticated.
There is a protocol
called Kerberos
that works this out in detail.
And that, again, is
described in the notes.
But the idea is just you put
the timestamp in every message
that you send.
And then when you
sign the message, when
the person on the other
end decodes that message,
they know that this
message was generated
as of a particular time.
But the third kind of attack
we might be worried about
is a so-called
impersonation attack.
And this is the attack that
this protocol is susceptible to.
Does anybody see what the
bug in this protocol is?
STUDENT: Charles
does not authenticate
that Alice is Alice.
Charles does not authenticate?
Well, Alice does send
this key that says --
Charles doesn't actually care
because all Charles saw was
a message that said I want
Alice's public key and B's
public key.
There is nothing wrong with
that message getting corrupted.
Alice might get something
back, but if it comes back
it has been signed with
Charles' private key
and so she will know exactly
what it was that was in there.
STUDENT: Only Alice knows
Charles private key?
I mean can't someone else
impersonate Alice and do
that whole process and then
be seen as Alice by Bob?
But notice that the
key has been signed
with Alice's private key.
This proposed key
has been signed
with Alice's private key.
STUDENT: Alice is sending
something encoded in Charles'
private key, is that right?
No.
Well, all this means
is that the thing that
is encoded with Charles'
private key, Bob
is going to be able to
decode that thing using
Charles' public key.
And he is going to
have some assurance,
in fact, about what
Alice's public key is.
I think that is OK.
Anybody else want
to take a guess?
OK.
Well, since we
are out of time, I
will talk about this the
first thing next time
and will show you what the
problem with this protocol is.
I will see you on Monday.
One announcement
before you guys go.
I have a little
gift for you guys
which is that we are going to
cancel class next Wednesday
before the design
project is due.
So there is no class
next Wednesday,
but there is class on Monday
so make sure you come here.